foreign
comes from Rachel in Kentucky our 19
year old daughter just moved out after
paying rent to us for the last eight
months my husband wants to consider the
money as hers and give it back to her
but I disagree currently she has zero
plans to go to college and has moved out
because we made her it was time
I was considering investing some of it
or using the money to pay for college
for our other daughter who will be
graduating high school next year
what's your opinion mom is hard mom is
feisty towards her daughter oh I bet if
it was a son
she'd give him the money oh 100
oh water on my daughters I feel like
than Charles my little baby boy little
baby boy
um I don't know Rachel let me think
um
I mean I think it's fine not to give it
back to her it does feel funny using her
money to pay for the other sister's
College
um would you give it back to her even if
she has no plans like she doesn't know
what she's gonna be doing
okay there's
something wrong with this situation that
is not money it was time for her to
leave and I'm going to take her money
and give it to her sister it kind of
sounds like we're a little pissed at
daughter
I don't know I think there's something
little there's a little friction here a
little Phillips between Mom it's time
for her to get out well hey I'm with you
kick him out I ain't got any problem
with that part but um get out there and
do your thing like you have to give her
back the money you don't have to but
don't not give it to her because you're
angry with her for her behavior and then
don't not give it to her and double down
on the punishment and give it to her
sister yeah that's that's that's a
little vindictive is the way it feels a
little bit here so uh by and large I I
think uh so that is kind of sad though
I'm thinking about my two daughters and
if I'm like I'm thinking you're so mad
at one of them you give it to the other
one yeah
it's like you little twerp I'm gonna
give it to your sister
um so yeah I I um
I I think your husband is probably
saying that uh giving your daughter back
this money is not a moral issue it's not
an ethical issue I don't think it is I
don't think you owe it to her
um I think her leaving with a little bit
of friction as she leaves sparks flying
uh as the uh as the old trunk was uh
drug out and thrown in the back of the
car or whatever we call it here
um
this would be just a little Grace um
I'm going to give it to her and just
call it Grace and just put it not to try
to buy her affection or to cover over
the misbehavior or something like that I
don't know what went on
but you you know you said it was time
for her to go so there's something
something a little bit pushy there and
because we made her because she made her
pleasure yeah
um
uh or maybe uh
she was doing nothing I mean she could
you know what I mean like yeah I don't
know so maybe you tie the giving money
back to her based on her behavior some
Behavior you want to encourage out there
in the wild
okay and so like um you know if you do
this or this we'll give you the money
we're going to give you this back or you
know like for instance and you know
honestly I kind of think Mom's pretty
upset whether there's a lot of emotion
in these words and I think probably mom
you step back and just ask your husband
to talk to her about it to the daughter
about it and uh because there seems to
be a little bit there and just say you
know we I think we might uh we might
want to help you in your new start
um and if you like went through about
you you're one through five or something
if you match your emergency fund or will
um you know or if you're gonna if you're
gonna pass some debt we'll help you with
that and we'll match that up you know
we're gonna use some of the money you
paid us in rent to help you get started
and to encourage some good behaviors if
you want to go through Financial Peace
University you know we would give you a
thousand dollars of this back as an
incentive to do that and something like
that something that helps the the
daughter that left get our get a
sustainable situation out there but now
I would not give it to her if she's
misbehaving out in the wild yeah and
you're going to finance her misbehavior
by giving her rent money back that's not
an act of love that's just enabling
so um yeah I so I I guess there's a lot
going on here that we don't know but
um
we are sure mom's hardcore no question
and I like her
great because they uh an eagle that
doesn't leave the nest is eventually
known as a turkey